what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and Marvel's secret invasion is over
however we have a lot of new exciting
Marvel projects coming up and luckily we
don't have to wait too much longer for
them the Marvels is going to be the next
MCU movie coming up and Captain America
Brave New World Isn't far behind and
we're hearing really good things about
this movie including Red Hulk a lot of
people have been wondering about Red
Hulk if he is actually going to appear
we have an update for you today and it's
all looking pretty good and in fact
Captain America Brave New World could
lead us to the world war Hulk movie that
we've been hearing about for some time
now now there's also going to be some
pretty big connections and consequences
in Captain America Brave New World that
are directly going to come from what we
just saw in secret Invasion and of
course like always we'll break down
everything that you need to know in this
video and reminder there are only a
couple of days left in our giveaway if
you want a chance to win an Xbox series
X A PS5 so Marvel Legends items or some
DC items all you have to do is subscribe
and leave a comment down below the
winner gets to pick one item and we pick
a winner at the end of each month only
three days left right now now something
that is really interesting about the
connection between secret Invasion and
Captain America Brave New World is that
you may have heard that Harrison Ford's
character Thunderbolt Ross and the
Marvel Cinematic Universe is going to be
the president the United States of
America well he obviously was not the
president in secret Invasion it was
President Ritson however at the end of
secret Invasion and minor spoiler alert
here while he was addressing the nation
and the world he says that we know the
scroll are among us and basically stated
that he is going to find them and kill
them and this resulted in some actual
humans getting killed innocent humans
getting killed and of course some skrull
getting killed as well and at the end he
talked to Nick Fury on the phone and
fury told him basically that's the kind
of decision that makes you president for
only one term so we can expect that his
four years as president comes to an end
and then Thunderbolt Ross runs for
president and beats him or there's going
to be so much killing of the scroll and
also real humans that he either gets
impeached or he resigns but either way
it will ultimately lead up to Harrison
Ford's Thunderbolt Ross becoming
president of the United States of
America and this is obviously kind of a
big deal because he is Red Hulk
Thunderbolt Russ or president Ross in
Captain America new world order has been
trying to recreate the super soldier
serum that was used on Captain America
for a pretty long time and considering
how he is going to be red Hulk in
Captain America 4 it seems like he is
still trying to create that recently The
Insider can we get some toast did an ask
me anything on Instagram where they
answered many questions and a few of
them were about Captain America 4. the
first question was what power up will
Sam Wilson receive in Captain America 4
and they responded with vibranium now
Captain America already has a vibranium
Shield so we can assume by this response
wants that they're not talking about the
shield but Sam Wilson's Captain America
suit Sam Wilson doesn't have super
soldier serum he's not enhanced in any
way and his blood and his DNA that we
know of so far at least so many fans
were wondering well how exactly is he
going to be able to essentially keep up
Steve Rogers was the Super Soldier
superhuman strength speed could heal
extremely quickly Sam Wilson doesn't
have any of that so how is he going to
handle the mantle of being Captain
America now and it looks like the answer
is vibranium a vibranium suit will give
him powers in a way just think of black
panther suits they have the ability to
absorb and release energy and since it's
going to be made out of vibranium I'm
assuming that there is some connection
to wakanda here maybe Sherry hooks him
up they obviously know each other they
fought alongside each other Sam was
there in Infinity war and wakanda we can
assume that Sam does get vibranium from
wakanda and he's going to need it
especially if there is going to be a red
Hulk in the movie and according to
another question that was asked on this
ask me anything they asked Red Hulk in
Brave New World in which the response
was absolutely so we know that
Thunderbolt Ross is Red Hulk in the
comics but that doesn't always
necessarily mean that that's what
they're going to do in the MCU and a lot
of fans were worried that we aren't
going to see a thunderbolt Ross turn
into Red Hulk but according to can we
get some toast we are going to see it
and other insiders have said this before
so it is essentially confirmed that we
will see Red Hulk in Brave New World and
in all honesty if they didn't do that it
would be just a huge missed opportunity
but luckily for us another question that
was asked and they asked me anything was
have you heard good things about Captain
America 4 in which they replied nothing
but good things especially about
Harrison Ford's performance as
Thunderbolt Ross so that's awesome
obviously Harrison Ford is a veteran
actor who has played many iconic roles
so this just adds to that list he's
obviously a great actor and now he's
going to be the Red Hulk and this of
course is going to go into the
Thunderbolts as well but we've also
heard that Captain America 4 Brave New
World is going to set up a couple of
other things one the new Avengers and
two possibly World War Hulk and if we
think about this this does make sense
because he was directly involved with
the Hulk's creation and obviously has a
huge history with Bruce Banner AKA The
Hulk and plus not to mention his
daughter Betty Ross because of course
his real name is Thaddeus Ross so his
daughter Betty Ross is the romantic love
interest of Bruce Banner and guess what
Liv Tyler is returning for Captain
America Brave New World and this is 100
confirmed she will be returning in the
movie so a lot of Hulk connections here
and apparently World War Hulk isn't
going to be what we think it is meaning
it's not going to be like a comic story
which makes sense because going into
Captain America 4 we're not going to
have a lot of things set up that they
had set up in the comics for example the
Illuminati were a pretty big part in the
comics and we don't have the Illuminati
in our universe and the MCU right now
not in the main timeline in the comics
the Illuminati tricked The Hulk and send
him off Earth because they think he's
too big of a threat he eventually goes
to scar becomes Gladiator Hulk which we
did see in Thor Ragnarok but then he
gets married and his wife gets pregnant
but then the ship that they sent him to
the other world on explodes so it kills
his wife and it kills his kid at least
he thought it killed his kid at the time
later on it's revealed that he survived
but the Hulk goes on a rampage and he
goes back to Earth and he beats everyone
even has a huge Coliseum and makes the
Fantastic Four in the Avengers and the
Heroes all fight each other doesn't seem
like that's gonna happen in Captain
America 4 or in the New World War Hulk
film rather it seems like it's going to
be kind of a battle between the hulks on
Earth since Thunderbolt Ross has been
experimenting with super soldier's serum
and since he is going to become the Red
Hulk in Captain America 4. it seems like
he might not be the only new Hulk that
is going to enter in the MCU in fact we
have heard from some insiders that there
are going to be more hulks so it seems
like World War whole might actually be
kind of in the most simplistic form a
battle on our world between the hulks
World War Hulk and we did just see the
Hulk's son scar who is from sakar they
did reveal that in She-Hulk so that's
another Hulk that's another piece to the
puzzle here and good luck Bruce Banner
explaining that you have a son now to
Betty Ross if you're trying to get back
with her which we could probably assume
that he would like to but it looks like
Captain America 4 is setting up some
really awesome things we do know that
directly after Captain America 4 the
Thunderbolts are coming and this is
going to be set up in the movie and like
I mentioned the new Avengers are
supposed to start to come together in
this film as well which makes sense
because once this film releases Avengers
the King Dynasty won't be that far away
and Sam Wilson's Captain America is said
to be the leader of the new Avengers
team much like Captain America was the
leader of the previous Avengers team so
the Avengers are about to make their
return and it sounds like Captain
America Brave new world is going to be
pretty epic and kind of more in line
with a traditional Marvel film and the
Insiders that we've heard from so far
have said nothing but great things about
the film so hopefully it is a great
movie that is connected to other Marvel
projects that also sets up future Marvel
projects as well which is what we've
really loved about the MCU and I
personally am really looking forward to
more hulks arriving in the MCU and a big
Hulk battle eventually hopefully in
World War Hulk but let us know your
thoughts about all of this in the
comments down below also don't forget to
like the video and subscribe so you can
stay up to date you can also find us on
patreon you can check out our website
and our Discord server and of course you
can always follow us on Instagram and
Twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof woof
foreign